marie sauce bureau qui est la présidente
des tops française et guillaume mais ce
qui est aussi le président des
cuisiniers de la république et le chef
de l'elysée nous envoyer des mails si
deux simultanément pour nous demander si
on pouvait répondre favorablement à une
quelque chose qui était mis en place
c'est d'améliorer le quotidien des
personnels hospitaliers
ça change un petit peu du menu qui sont
l'habitude d'avoir si on pouvait alors
une petite partie gastronomique au
niveau des repas en évitant bien sûr des
repense aussi parce qu'on sait que ces
gens là ne peuvent pas s'asseoir la
plupart du temps pour soigner le
personnel qui les gens qui sont malades
le personnel ne peut pas s'asseoir dans
qui vont justement l'ont ramené quelque
chose qu'ils vont pouvoir manger
facilement donc aujourd'hui on est dans
une je dirais une petite démarche où on
en prend de contacter certains
fournisseurs alimentaire pour qu'on
puisse répondre farrar noblement à 7
cette initiative qui mis en fin de
compte sur les yvelines et sur toute la
france parce que vous avez des chefs et
des grands chefs comme michel sarro qui
aussi d'autres chefs qui font pas partie
des tops qui réponde favorablement à ce
qu'on a mis un petit peu en place avec
l'étape française et pourquoi vous vous
êtes lancé du coup dans l'initiative
pourquoi essayer d'y répondre
favorablement
alors moi j'ai toujours l'esprit vous
savez très bien des concurrents de
service je le fais j'ai d'autant un
intérêt plus personnel il ya quelques
années je dirais l'hôpital mignot a
sauvé la vie de mon épouse j'ai aussi le
membre d'une dynamique qui travaillent
là bas je connais ces conditions très
difficiles très particulière de je me
suis dit que c'était bien justement de
leur apporter un petit peu de réconfort
j'ai eu l'occasion de discuter un petit
peu avec elle ils sont tout à fait ravi
déjà des kits démarches ont été faites
par des boulangers ne mord pas avec qui
je connais donc on est des dépeint des
choses comme ça mais cirque aujourd'hui
on voudrait vraiment les ramener un
petit peu un réconfort parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est une lutte h 24
justement pour soigner un petit peu tous
les patients qui sont là bas aussi on
vient justement sur la démarche de
concocter des plats pour le personnel
soignant vous lui disiez vous êtes vous
en phase de démarrage c'est le début de
la 2 de cette phase pour pouvoir
proposer c'est certain tout à fait avoir
longtemps phase de démarrage on
bien sûr contacter des entreprises ne
mord pas il ya des logistiques un petit
peu à mettre parce qu'aujourd'hui compte
tenu d'un petit peu du jeu dit elle on
peut pas faire ce qu'on veut donc qu'ils
peuvent pas non plus on est des traces
de traçabilité du frais bien sûr à
sortir et 6,6 produit justement peut pas
livrer n'importe comment il faut comme
garantir une sécurité alimentaire au
niveau du personnel j'ai un ami qui est
un laboratoire de traiteur qui
aujourd'hui est prêt justement à me
prêter son laboratoire pour pouvoir
établir ses plats dans les meilleures
conditions et bien sûr pouvoir les
transporter dans les meilleures
conditions
c'est qu'aujourd'hui depuis vendredi on
a avancé beaucoup en attente de trois
réponses qui devrait arriver dans les 24
48 heures justement pour avoir des
denrées alimentaires et pouvoir répondre
favorablement à cette demande qui fait
justement pas aussi les hôpitaux de
paris et l'objectif c'est de le mettre
en place dans un premier temps pour le
personnel de mignot c'est peut-être
aussi que d'autres confrères cuisinier
répondre favorablement à l'appel dans
les yvelines que ce soit tout le
territoire qui soit peut-être couleurs
voilà cirque aujourd'hui cet appel any
man sur millau il ya un autre collègue
qui s'occupe de paris mais j'y réponds
sur des îles il ya plein de pitot qui
ont besoin de ce genre de choses
aujourd'hui je sais qu'il ya des chefs
on est lancé un petit peu les
convocations pour ce qu'ils pouvaient
répondre favorablement s'est répandue
sur les yvelines et bien sûr ça
répandues sont tout le territoire
français
là où il ya des hôpitaux qui méritait
que des chefs libre que moi justement
peuvent un petit peu s'investir tout en
respectant bien sûr les consignes